remember religious hero Kim Davis the
Rowan County Clerk who suffered a
five-day incarceration for not marrying
gay people and then went on a worldwide
anti-gay media tour to tell us that the
First Amendment lets you do whatever you
want as long as you say it's your
religion oh what an amazing way to get
famous but now a sinister someone wants
to stand in her way and it happens to be
one of the gay guys whose way she stood
in we went down the clerk's office and
we're denied a marriage license
repeatedly and then she told us you know
basically that we were gonna have to
face God right and his judgment this is
David ermold and this is Kim Davis
denying David a marriage license and
this is David registering with Kim to
try and take her job as County Clerk
drama David ermold returned to the Rowan
County Courthouse yesterday with his
husband he met with Davis as he filed
his paperwork to run for office so we're
in Kentucky to discover the menacing
motivations of who would be clerk would
you say this is a revenge part oh
absolutely I would like to restore the
integrity of the office down there I
would like to restore the reputation of
Rowan County you know we are a wonderful
place to live because you wouldn't be
the first you know okay person to seek
revenge right Buffalo Bill Ursula Jafar
isn't that funny yeah don't you think
you're taking away
Kim's and a label rights to take away
other people's an alien rights she
doesn't have the right to take other
people's rights away isn't it in the
Constitution somewhere no absolutely not
oh I gotta read that thing it's just so
I should not have to drive five miles
down the road
in order to get the same service that a
straight couple walking into that office
would get oh so he'd offer the same
surfaces to everyone well we decided to
put that to the test what if this couple
came in what'd you give them a marriage
license sure okay well actually the
couple is this dog and this
this is just their fun friend yeah okay
well then how about this couple sure
sure
well what you don't know is they're
looking at a video on their laptop
called how to be an Isis you just
married gay Isis this is America's
premier gay Isis couple I'd hate to be
in your shoes so david has locked into
gay Isis dog folk but as Kim Davis's
lawyer pointed out all David has is one
issue not like Kim Kim is much more
qualified to be County Clerk she met the
Pope to talk about gay marriage she
taught Romania how gay people shouldn't
be married and she's writing a goddamn
book about scary gay people you know
typical county clerk stuff and not a
single issue candidate is David even
qualified for the job I have two masters
degrees from Morehead State University
well how long did that take
14 years no it only took me four years
it took me eight to get an undergrad
yeah that's really good communication in
English is what I majored in there so I
teach at a Christian University right
now see that's the thing though you're a
teacher so how are you gonna learn to do
this new job you're not learn or you're
a teacher it's the opposite no it's a
leadership position and you have to
manage a team of people in order to make
sure that they're doing their jobs
correctly I'm worried because you seem
qualified and motivated and you're
worried because well I just think you
could win right we've sort of sticked a
lot of claim on being the only two gay
guys who like Kim Davis so well I'm
sorry you made the wrong choice oh no
you can staple file
Andy has embroidered hats he can do this
job and he's qualified but if people
like david win then what's going to
happen to elected officials who use a
crude understanding of the Constitution
to impose their religious beliefs on
others our politicians are not going to
stand up for our rights then it's up to
us to actually do that ourselves
[Music]
[Applause]
we finally found her Kim Davis did you
know there's qualified candidates
running against you know the upcoming
election yeah and he doesn't even want
to use religion to take away people's
rights and that apparently has made a
lot of people upset so we all wanted to
warn you media Horta media or let you
know yes we're like you will do
basically this cookie do you still have
Huckabee's number because we need him to
tell her mold not to run but you MA keep
fighting the good fight camera writer we
warned Kim me stop sipping engagement
David Ramona that's done with our help
Kim can still win we just have to make
sure that no one goes to David ermold
calm to learn more about the election
that's on may 22nd
[Music]